hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video guys i
want to make a full update on the global
market i want to go through spy and
triple q price action let's get into it
[Music]
oh right guys i was talking about a bull
trap in my last video even in my two
last videos guys and we had one so let's
let's analyze the situation i'm gonna go
from triple q to spy and because
everything happened together of course
so let's start on triple q alright guys
i did my last video so five days ago
around here we were consolidating guys
you know below this trend line you see
we were having you know some uh drop in
volume
some early signs of reversal you know a
lot of investors were feeling like uh
the correction might be over but this is
how b waves actually happen all right
they make you think the correction is
over they give you a bull trap and then
you have the sea wave all right so of
course there are there is some news
related so here we have the inflation
numbers that happened on the 10th of fab
that were a little bit higher than
expected which of course scared the
market
but there is always a news that is going
to scare the market you know what i mean
what is important in trading is the news
interpretation not the news itself if
the market is bullish if there is a
strong bullish sentiment bad news that
is still going to be both okay and good
news are going to be bought even more
so of course the news do the market but
what really does the market is the
interpretation of the news so here i
think that whatever the news would have
been the market would have sold that's
what i mean the bet the sentiment was
bearish guys okay the long-term
sentiment i mean medium term sentiment
was bearish and we had the catalyzer
which was the inflation number so let's
analyze before what happened so if i
check
here guys so we have this trend line
okay i'm connecting the highs that are
here
this high as well and we were
considerating here and then we jump
above this on that day guys okay above
this trend line
you know
above the 20-day moving average and guys
i'm keeping this all right because i
remind you quickly what i was saying in
my last video is that if you want to
make the difference between a b wave and
a new bullish cycle you need to check at
the volume and at the volatility okay
it's very important once again if you're
interested to know more about how to use
those indicators to trade a breakout
because here it's a very good example of
a fake out that of course should not
have been traded click on the link in
description of this video and you're
gonna receive guys my full course very
soon so i i still need two three weeks
maximum to prepare everything
so just subscribe so that i get your
email and i'm gonna send you all the
information with the massive discount
that i will do at the beginning of
course so let's apply the method i'm
trying to give you guys in this course
and here basically on the on the
trackers it's a little bit different
because trackers you know of the global
market involve always huge volume during
corrections so the volume increase would
always be lighter but it needs at least
to be stable all right for this breakout
to be good quality and here
i mean it's the lowest volume that has
been traded since the
the beginning of the correction so this
was telling you guys that this
breakout is a fake out okay and it
didn't take long to fake out sometimes
it even takes a little bit more time
it's
even a little bit trickier here it was
not the case it corrected right away all
right so at least you know
it's done okay so what can happen from
now so first spy same thing guys okay
same trend line
uh same extremely low volume on this
breakout and same fake out right after
so
is the b wave complete b waves should
happen in three waves abc i mean it
could be complete guys it couldn't be
complete we could have a small abc
inside this abc all right abc here so it
looks like this is complete let me put
this
just 100 degree minutes okay so it looks
like the b wave is complete
and that was starting a c wave
i i thought it would happen a little bit
later i still took a short position here
like i said guys for those who are
following me on this code you know i
gave you the level uh to take this short
position once again because i'm just
following you know the basic resistance
levels that were here and this was
usually the levels where the b wave
likes to go so let me just show you that
quickly bam so i think that this is what
is coming edge this is what is coming
and very quickly for the top of the b
wave
bam once again everything is explained
in the course you measure the a wave and
61.8 percent three here 78 377 was the
top of the b wave so here it was missed
uh but we still had the lows uh off the
breakout that were here and that could
be used to start building a short
position so once again what i did
personally i sold 370 i entered here
guys and once again for those who are
with me in this code you know it's true
and i wanted to add more on the upside
which i couldn't do but i'm still short
in this market right now to protect my
long investment
and i think that this is what is coming
guys one two three four five okay it
looks like we are in the middle of a
third wave right with a minor three
percent third waves are usually very
impulsive with huge moves a lot of
volume so here the volume is bigger it's
not an extremely big volume yet so
let's see guys but monday might be
bloody all right monday might be bloody
and if it is
then it makes things easier because then
we're gonna probably have a false wave
correction
okay
and then a fifth wave so here you can
take another short position it's not
easy to take profits here or even by the
dip because first this is going to be
very shallow between three and four and
it's very hard to know how deep the
third wave of the sea wave can go so
buying here
is not easy
selling here is i mean it's never easy
but it's a trade that is easier to make
we just need to find where would be the
resistance we're going to be looking for
that of course guys so that's what i
think might happen so for spy
same thing guys
so i'm giving you this scenario for
quite some time for now i'm very correct
about everything that is happening so
let's see if i'm still correct you know
you never know trading is about
probabilities guys so i think this is
what we are seeing right now guys okay
bam zero
one two
okay and we are the third wave so the
third wave might go to you know
430
and then four and five guys
so
i mean this is a
this is a scenario that makes sense so
of course the best thing to do guys is
to wait for the market to be around 400
415
and to buy all right guys this is what
i'm gonna do okay and i'm short right
now so i'm just gonna take profits on
the way down and i'm gonna reload a
massive long position if i see those uh
trackers close to this levels so that's
it for today guys i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything new and stay
close to floor i see you guys